last year's new year's resolution to
help the national vaccine programme
[Music]
nearly a thousand hours later and nobody
in the east of england has volunteered
more hours than alex spence
it's all about them getting to do things
when they're freed up from this so we
had a lady the other day where she said
i've literally saved her wedding because
she needed a vaccination within the next
two days or she wasn't going to be able
to get to barbados for the wedding it's
not just wedding days being saved
volunteer contribution is also helping
keep pressure off and nhs under strain
despite record-breaking vaccination
figures this past fortnight omicron
remains on the rise and the nhs is
taking no chances
this is a new temporary nightingale hub
being built
one of an initial eight sites across
england
in london the hub will be here at st
george's hospital nhs trusts have been
asked to help identify more sites like
gyms and education centers that can be
converted to help create up to four
thousand so-called super surge beds the
expansion comes as the number of people
in hospitals with covid rose above ten
thousand for the first time since march
what we're doing here is we're preparing
for the worst whilst hoping for the best
it's it's a no regrets approach what you
don't want to do is hit a point where
you need to treat very large numbers of
patients but you simply don't have the
facilities and capacity to do it
questions remain over who will staff the
new hubs the royal college of nursing
has sounded the alarm over worker
shortages and low morale
a survey of more than 9 000 uk nursing
staff has found that 57 said they're
considering or planning on leaving their
job
around three quarters said that in the
last year they'd worked when feeling
unwell
and 18 said they weren't able to take
annual leave we've got a nursing
profession that's under intolerable
pressures
it's a workforce and crisis and if we
don't address the crisis in the nursing
profession then we won't have a health
and care service that's fit to deliver
for those that are in desperate need of
it and deserve actually the care and
that the health service should be able
to deliver the nightingale surge hubs
become the latest response to the rapid
spread of omicron and the prospect of
another major wave of people relying on
the nhs for treatment
sadia chowdhury sky news